yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
and today i'm bringing you guys some
fallout form news now this is actually
not something too big and it's not even
really about the actual content of
fallout 4 just about the release of
fallout force now a lot of people are
going really crazy about a possible
change to the release date of fallout 4
and i just want to let you guys know
that it isn't anything to be worried
about it's nothing big it's the
technically was a change at least on
scheme but it's nothing that you would
tend to think it would be for a release
date change if you'd like a fall for on
steam you can see that it says the game
will be available on november nine
that's kind of important because the
games was released on november tent but
if you look at when the game will unlock
approximately and you take into the
account your time zone and when it
should release on your time zone it
should still be the same of basically at
midnight local time if it's not that and
say you're in North America then it's
1201 a.m. eastern time as we know from
before but it's nothing there's no
significant change fallout 4 is still
releasing around midnight locally on
November 10 however if you're in North
America then it's obviously a little bit
before unless you live on these coasts
and also we can look at Pete Hines as
Twitter behinds a general community
manager and he's answered the question
dozens of times on whether fall for will
release earlier you just continually
posted the link to the picture when
Bethesda talked about their release time
and when it's going to be releasing and
it is still the same it's nothing to
worry about fallout 4 is still going to
release the same time you aren't going
to be gypped out of anything if people
are saying it's going to come out
earlier you're like wait know what I'm
still gonna play the normal time don't
worry there's nothing to fret about it
it's nothing the release date
technically changed from like 12 01 a.m.
to 1150 9am on steam oven 59 p.m. sorry
on steam but it's like two minutes so
it's not a big deal so if you guys
enjoyed this video is a quick little
update to be just fall out for release
date and yeah I will be posting a lot
more fought for so if you're checking
out more fallout 4 be sure to continue
to check out my channel since i'ma be
hosting tons of it you already see some
of the stuff I have up obviously the
game hasn't come out yet so I haven't
been able to do too much so thank you
guys for watching peace out